- Mon génie à moi est de plus
en plus près des anges.
- Salvador Dali était
un des grands maîtres
du surréalisme. Et coup
de théâtre : son immense toile
intitulée "Nuages",
qui n'a jamais été exposée
dans un musée, refait
surface à Montréal.
FÉLIX BÉLANGER, coproducteur
de l'exposition "Divina Dali"
- Et des oeuvres de cette
grandeur-là que Dali a faites,
il n'y en a pas beaucoup.
- Cette oeuvre de 6 mètres
par 9 mètres avait été créée
à l'été 1944 comme décor
pour le film "La Maison
du Dr Edwardes",
d'Alfred Hitchcock.
- Et il avait une petite
roue à la main.
RAYNALD MICHAUD, commissaire
de l'exposition "Divina Dali"
- La commande par M. Hitchcock
à Dali, c'était d'illustrer
le rêve à l'époque
de la psychanalyse et tout.
- Après la sortie du film,
la toile était tombée dans
l'oubli. C'est finalement
une collectionneuse française
qui l'a vendue aux producteurs
de la nouvelle exposition
"Divina Dali".
- Elle nous l'a vendue,
mais à un très, très bon prix.
Je ne peux pas en parler.
Mais, oui, elle a été
très accommodante.
- Cette toile évocatrice
est une invitation à nous mettre
la tête dans les nuages.
- On peut y projeter, comme
disait Félix, ce qu'on veut.
Une oeuvre d'art, c'est ça.
- Moi, depuis que je la connais,
puis que je l'ai vue,
je retourne devant un vrai ciel
et je vois le nuage de Dali.
On n'arrive pas à l'oublier.
Il inverse la proposition
dans le cerveau.
Il inverse les polarités.
(rires)
- "Nuages" fera partie
d'une exposition intitulée
"Divina Dali" et regroupant
100 estampes réalisées
par Dali dans les années 1950
pour rendre hommage
aux 100 chants du chef-d'oeuvre
"la Divine Comédie",
du poète italien Dante.
- Ça se divise en trois phases :
il y a l'enfer, le purgatoire
et le paradis. On présente
vraiment les 100 oeuvres.
Et par le plus merveilleux
des hasards, c'est 700 ans
après le décès de Dante.
- Quand je dis que je suis
un très génie, je le dis par
rapport à mes contemporains.
- Salvadore Dali, décédé
en 1989, a été sans aucun doute
un des grands génies
du 20e siècle. Sa toile
"Nuages", nouvelle débarquée
à Montréal, pourrait y rester
encore pour longtemps.
- On rêve de lui trouver
son endroit permanent
où l'installer, à Montréal.
Dans mon rêve à moi,
c'est là qu'elle doit rester.
- L'exposition "Divina Dali" est
présentée au Grand Quai du Port
de Montréal dès le 16 juillet.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, M